[Musique]
eh bien oui je suis une femme et j'ose
me présenter comme candidate à la
présidence de cette république d'homme
c'est légal et pourtant cela choque cela
paraît étrange même aux hommes de gauche
et cela doit l'être puisque je suis la
seule certes les grands partis se disent
tous partisans de l'égalité des hommes
et des femmes et ils n'en finissent pas
de voter et de re voter des lois sur
cette égalité mais quand il s'agit de
donner des responsabilités quand il
s'agit de commandes et de diriger alors
tous ces hommes là considère que cela
doit rester une affaire d'hommes
bien sûr parmi eux personne n'ose dire
que les femmes ne sont pas capables
d'exercer telle ou telle fonction mais
dans les faits quelle place font-ils aux
femmes sur plusieurs centaines de
ministres qui se sont succédé depuis 30
ans seulement deux femmes
huit femmes aujourd'hui au parlement sur
480 députés et cela parce que tous les
partis en place tous les hommes
politiques qu'ils soient de droite ou de
gauche ne mettent pas leurs actes en
accord avec leurs paroles là comme
ailleurs ils mentent la preuve c'est
qu'aucun grand parti n'a juge est une
femme digne de leur présenter à ces
élections
à l'usiné au bureau dans les services
les femmes n'ont que des emplois
subalternes
alors que les hommes sont en majorité
des cadres l'immense majorité des femmes
qui travaillent sont commandés par des
hommes en bien sûr on nous parle à la
radio et à l'école de la dignité d'être
mère et de l'importance du rôle de la
mère dans la famille et dans la société
mais toutes les femmes qui travaillent
et qui ont dû demander à leur chef une
autorisation d'absence pour soigner un
enfant malade savent parfaitement quel
rebuffade et quelle réflexion elles
doivent essuyer
voilà la réalité et il faut la dire les
femmes c'est à dire la moitié de la
population de ce pays n'ont pas des
salaires égaux à ceux des hommes non pas
des postes ego non pas des droits égaux
à ceux des hommes elles sont considérées
comme des citoyens de seconde zone et
traités comme tels ce sont des colonisés
des étrangères dans leur propre pays
votre société messieurs les politiciens
n'est pas sorti de la barbarie et c'est
vous qui lui maintenait y compris vous
sommes de gauche car n'oublions pas que
même le front populaire en 1936 n'avait
pas donné le droit de vote aux femmes
dans ce pays il a fallu attendre la fin
de la guerre 1945 pour que ce soit
octroyée aux femmes le droit de vote et
voilà qui montre d'ailleurs les limites
du bulletin de vote pour changer notre
sort car ce n'est pas parce que les
femmes ont le droit de vote aujourd'hui
que ce ne sont pas toujours les hommes
qui décident pour l y compris en ce qui
nous concerne nous directement les
femmes c'est une assemblée d'hommes qui
discute depuis des mois voire depuis des
années de savoir si les femmes ont le
droit d'interrompre ou pas une grossesse
non désirée eux parle de morale de
liberté de droits mais tolère avec
cynisme l'inégalité flagrante
systématique inique dont les femmes sont
victimes
alors comme l'on dit des centaines de
milliers de femmes en signant une
pétition récente je ne suis pas un homme
politique je ne suis pas médecin je ne
suis pas juriste je suis une femme et
j'exige le droit de décider moi même si
je dois ou pas avoir des enfants et
combien et pour que ces politiciens
acceptent aujourd'hui avec combien de
réticences et de dérobade de discuter de
modifier la loi il a fallu que des
femmes courageuses disent publiquement
oui j'ai avorté il a fallu que des
médecins hommes et femmes bravent la loi
et l'autorité judiciaire en proclamant
oui j'ai pratiqué des avortements
il a fallu que secret le mouvement pour
la lie certes et de l'avortement et de
la contraception le black et tous ceux
qui participent à ce combat ne sont pas
prêts à laisser l'assemblée nationale
décide des sols et à s'incliner devant
ces décisions car les bourgeois qui se
disent partisans de la libéralisation de
la loi sur l'avortement et ceux qui en
sont adversaire partageant fait la même
hypocrisie fondamental car le problème
le problème se posait aussi avec la même
acuité
monsieur mitterrand quand vous étiez
garde des sceaux ministre
en 1956 il faut que ces choses-là soit
dit car il n'y a aucune femme dans ce
pays qu'elle soit bourgeoise ouvrière
qui n'ait été un jour ou l'autre
confrontés avec le problème d'une
grossesse non désirée et il n'y a aucune
femme qui n'a senti alors toute la
détresse de sa situation et qu'ils ne se
soient révoltés comme contre une
législation
rétrograde et hypocrite elles ont alors
réagi selon leur moral et surtout selon
leurs moyens mais tout en ont été
profondément marquées pour toutes les
femmes de ce pays je réclame le droit à
la contraception ainsi que le droit car
c'est un droit d'interrompre une
grossesse non désirée en bénéficiant de
toutes les garanties médicales pour les
socialistes révolutionnaires
l'égalité de l'homme et de la femme
n'est pas un droit c'est un fait si la
femme occupe aujourd'hui une situation
inférieure à celle de l'homme
ce n'est pas dû à son manque de
capacités qui n'existe que dans la tête
des réactionnaires c'est parce que nous
vivons dans une société d'exploitation
une société qui repose sur la justice et
sur l'inégalité et les femmes toutes les
femmes y compris celle de la bourgeoisie
sont victimes de cette société
d'exploitation bien sûr certaines ont
des cages dorées mais ce sont des cages
quand même il suffit de voir avec quelle
impudence en cette période d'élections
tous ministre pousse en avant leurs
femmes ou leurs filles comme ils
exhibent leur propriété ou leur titre et
s'il ya des femmes à qui s'appelait et
bien tant pis pour elle ce n'est pas
elle que je m'adresse mais à toutes
celles qui aspirent à être heureux nus
comme des êtres humains à part entière
et si des femmes de la bourgeoisie ne
vote pas pour moi parce que je suis une
militante d'extrême gauche cela ne me
gêne pas mais elles ont tort car elles
ont le choix entre leur conscience de
classe et leur conscience d'être humain
car c'est précisément parce que
j'appartiens à un mouvement
révolutionnaire que je suis là ce soir
et que je peux parler pour toutes les
femmes ce n'est pas la seule raison pour
laquelle je me présente mais c'en est
une importante je parlerai des autres
dans mes prochaines interventions mais
si je suis la seule candidate féminine
ce n'est pas hasard et toutes les femmes
qui en sont conscientes doivent le mark
et le 5 mai en votant pour ma
candidature
[Musique]